how important was
data to newton okay so like you
mentioned uh prism and playing with it
and looking at stuff and then coming up
with calculations and so on where does
data fit into any of his ideas
all right well let me say two things
first one we rarely use the phrase
scientific method anymore because there
is no one
easily
describable such method and certainly i
mean humans have been playing around
with the world and learning how to
repetitively do things and make things
happen ever since you know humans became
humans
um
do you have a preferred definition of
the scientific method what are the
various uh no i don't
i prefer to talk about
the
considered
manipulation of artificial structures to
produce results that can be
worked together with schemes to
construct other devices and make
predictions if you will about the way
such things will work
so ultimately it's about producing other
devices it's like leads you down
i think so principally
i mean you may have
data if you will like astronomical data
obtained otherwise and so on but yes
and but but but number two here is this
question of data what is data
in that sense see when we talk about
data today
um we have
a kind of complex notion which
reverts to even issues of statistics
and measurement procedures and so on
so
let me put it to you this way so
let's say i had a ruler in front of me
go on and it's marked off in little
black marks separated by let's say
distances
called a millimeter
okay now i make a mark on this piece of
paper here so i made a nice
black mark right
nice black mark
and i ask you i want you to measure that
and tell me how long it is
you're going to take the ruler
you're going to put it next to it
and you're going to look
and it's not going to sit even if you
put one end as close as you can on one
black mark the other end probably isn't
going to be exactly on a black mark well
you'll say it's closer to this or that
you write down a number and i say okay
take the ruler away a minute i take this
away come back in five minutes put the
piece of paper down do it again
you're gonna probably come up with a
different number
and you're gonna do that a lot of times
and then if i tell you i want you to
give me your best estimate of what the
actual length of that thing is what are
you going to do
you're going to
average all of these numbers
why
statistics
well yes
statistics there's lots of ways of going
around it but the average is the best
estimate on the basis of what's called
the central limit theorem
a statistical thing we were talking
about things
that were not really developed until the
1750s 60s and 70s newton died in 1727.
the intuition perhaps was there not
really i'll tell you what people did
including newton although newton is
partially the one exception
we talked a while ago about this guy
christian huygens
he measured lots of things and he was a
good
mechanic himself he and his brother
ground lenses huygens i told you
developed the first pendulum mechanism
pendulum driven clock with a mechanism
and so on also
a spring watch where he got into a
controversy with hook over that by the
way
um well these mechanics and the
controversy yeah
well we also have
huygens's notes
um they're preserved at the at leiden
university in holland he's dutch
for his work in optics which was
extensive we don't have time to go into
that except the following
a number of years ago i went through
those things because in this optical
theory that he had
there are four
numbers that you've got to be able to
get good numbers on to be able to
predict other things
so what would we do today what in fact
was done at the end of the 18th century
when somebody went back to this you do
what you just i told you to do with the
ruler you make a lot of measurements and
average results
we have huygens notes he did make a lot
of measurements
one after the other after the other
but when he
came to use the numbers for calculations
and indeed when he published things
at the end of his life
he gives you one number and it's not the
average of any of them it's just one of
them
which one was it the one that he thought
he got
so good at
working by practice that he put down the
one he was most confident in
that was the general procedure
at the time you wouldn't publish a paper
in which you wrote down six numbers and
said well i measured this six times let
me put them together none of them is
really
they would have said the right number
but i'll put them together and give you
a good number no you would have been
thought of that you know you don't know
what you're doing yeah
by the way there's just an inkling of
value to that approach
just an inkling
we sometimes use statistics as like a
thing that like oh that solves all the
problems
we'll just do a lot of it and we'll take
the average or whatever it is as many
excellent books on mathematics have
highlighted the flaws in our approach to
certain sciences
that rely heavily on statistics
you